former president donald trump meeting
with texas leaders today at the
epicenter
of the crisis that state forced to take
matters into its own hands to stop the
surge of migrants
and drugs flooding into the country the
former president and governor abbott
going after president biden during their
visit to the border earlier take a look
you look at this border and you look
what you see
you see an unfinished border
this is biden's fault president biden
needs to start right there
and finish building the border wall the
increase in the number of people coming
across the border
from last april to this april is almost
a thousand percent
we're not only talking about people
millions of people are coming in
but we're talking about drugs we're
talking about human trafficking all
biden had to do is go to the beach
if he would have just done nothing we
would have now the strongest border
we've ever had it was even getting
better and better and better because it
was all kicking in
and the former president and governor
abbott are sitting down with sean
hannity
for a town hall tonight at 9 00 p.m so
jesse biden actually does
happen to go to the beach quite often
when he goes to delaware
rehoboth right but one other thing that
president trump said today was that look
the biden administration as either
incompetent or
they are totally fine with what's
happening because they aren't trying to
stop it
i think it's designed to break the
border and
they're sadistic because they're hurting
people they're hurting children
there's child trafficking sex
trafficking
you're looking at these overdose numbers
now it's tens of thousands of americans
through fentanyl and they're there two
pounds of fentanyl can kill half a
million americans
two pounds and they're getting record
amounts of fentanyl record amounts of
meth coming through
and now there's a report from cbs that's
saying the kids in cages are
suicidal and they're confiscating any
sharp objects because they're trying to
off themselves
because they're horribly depressed and
they're having
panic attacks they're trying to escape
from the cages that joe is keeping them
in and donald trump's down there he's
boots on the ground he's trying to
highlight what's going on but i don't
think the media is going to use this
as an opportunity to highlight the
broken border they're going to spin it
make it personal make it about trump
and just lead with cosby or something
else and that's a shame
because americans are dying we led with
cosby
we did but they won't even cover this
and we cover this all the time they
never cover it
i mean you're told that cnn is currently
on the border but you know who are we
so let's talk about it
[Applause]
evening news all right harold uh let's
talk about the contrast
between the current vice president who
decided to go to el paso
far far away from where this is really
happening and the former president
visiting
today with the with the wall behind them
that is unfinished that's of course
a divided administration policy so what
about that contrast this is clearly
an issue that americans care about so i
think democrats
ought to try to work a deal here and the
deal ought to be
let's finish the wall and then let's
figure out how we address some of these
underlying causes that in root causes
i think you got to try to find some sort
of coalition i might add just a point of
lightness and levity here
if visiting the border would solve our
immigration challenge or the border
surge challenge
this problem would have been solved a
long time ago with lindsey graham and
marco rubio and ted cruz and
president trump and other presidents
who've gone there before i get the
politics of it but if we only want to
play the politics every two years
then this is what we should keep doing
if we want to try to solve this then
we've got to look at the three parts of
this the messaging
the border democrats ought to agree to
build out this wall
if republicans are agreeing to will
agree to some root causes investments
in figuring out what we do with with the
number of undocumented people here in
america who will pay
tax pay their taxes and get on a path
the right way to citizenship
that ought to be the plan but dana isn't
that the borders are the current vice
president's
job actually is to do all of those three
things and instead of seeing it
firsthand she went somewhere and didn't
actually get the kind of briefing that
president trump and governor abbott gave
today well i think it's also going to be
very telling if by if by the end of july
she hasn't presented some sort of policy
recommendation to the president
that they can support then i think that
you have to say it was a failed mission
um already it looks like it's pretty bad
but
i think maybe by the end of july like
are you going to be able to come back
and say you've done
something but that she wants to deal
with root causes
root causes take a long time to deal
with actually you could deal with a
couple of things right away that could
help mitigate the problem
for example jesse mentioned children the
mexican immigration officials
found a two-year-old boy on the side of
the road they had been abandoned
he was surrounded by trash he's there
he's two years old so there he is right
there
so i mean there's root causes and you
can deal with the economics of guatemala
and law and order in guatemala okay fine
but one of the things that they can't
even support are things that are already
there to help them
for example yesterday yvette herrell
republican congresswoman
forced a vote on the house floor in
which it said please do not remove title
42 which basically is the public health
rule that says
because of kovid you can turn people
back away from the border
the bright administration is about to
repeal that why would you do that
because it's given you a tool to help
you deal with the actual real emergency
but the democrats blocked it right so i
think that
unfortunately we're kind of in this
vortex but
what the media will cover is the other
trump story or they'll split-screen it
right they'll say
trump went to the border and his uh
organization is going to get
it tomorrow that's what they'll do there
you go yeah so greg
dana's question why would they continue
to make this worse
not to mention offer solutions to make
it better i have a theory but first if
that two-year-old was found during the
trump administration
that child would be on the cover of
every magazine including better homes
and gardens
and cnn anchors would be shaking with
rage
yes crying they would be crying um so t
why are they making it worse my theory
is ebe evil by extension i've talked
about this in the past
it's a curse of today's thinking it's
not just x that's evil
it's everything linked to x right so the
problem with trump is
he's had a lot of really great ideas
but they're evil by extension because
they come from him the wall is a perfect
example
just the thought of it worked right
everybody understood it but
it's evil same as the wuhan lab theory
that was but that was his idea so it's
evil
and so i was thinking like why is it
that all of the institutions
are getting softer like like if you talk
about either the border
or anywhere it's because trump's
positions were always the tough position
so stance on the border very very tough
no-nonsense
law order for example very tough on
crime cnn suddenly becomes pro-antifa
so you see what happens it's like
because he's x they have to be anti-x
kovid he said it's china china china
what happens
fauci and the media is saying no no no
no no so what happens is it's it's
this is why i think that it is often
just a lost cause
once it has nothing to do with the issue
or the idea once you stake out a
position
in team sport politics the other side
has to take the other side
so even if trump's all of a sudden if
trump said i'm for open borders
cnn in the media would be for the wall
well maybe that's what he should have
done today
this wall is terrible you should tear it
down immediately
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else